نجح الديمقراطيون في درع موجه حمراء بعد
حمله انتخابيه مشحونه وتوقعات عززتها
اوضاع اقتصاديه متعثره ودروس تاريخيه
ترجح كفه الحزب المعارض
الجمهوريون استعدوا الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب بينما عزز الديمقراطيون اغلبيتهم
في مجلس الشيوخ بمقعد اضافي
الايام الاخيره من السيطرهم على مجلس
النواب لنشر البيانات
جنائيه
تحقيقات في احداث السادس
من ردود فعل عنيفه من مؤيده
ترامب لكن على وزاره العدل تاخذ ذلك في
الحسبان وعليها محاسبته اذا كانت تعتقد
انه ارتكب جرمان
على صحه الدوليه ازدادت
علاقتهرا بسبب الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا
كما فرضت واشنطن عقوبات غير مسبوقه على
الاقتصاد الروسي من فرض حظر على والده
النفط والغاز الروسي الى عقوبه في حق
افراد ومؤسسات مصرفيه الى عقوبه حرم
الصناعه الاسلحه الروسيه من الوصول الى
التكنولوجيا الامريكيه
وفي الوقت الذي وجد فيه اداء الرئيس بيدن
استحسانا داخليا في موضوع اوكرانيا واجه
اداءه انتقادا في باقي الملفات الدوليه
بالمفاوضات مع ايران في حين ان العلاقه مع
الصين ما تزال متوتره وتواصل كوريا
الشماليه تجاربها الصاروخيه
على المستوى الاقتصادي ظلت نسب البطاله
متدنيه وبدات اسعار الوقود بالتراجع لكنني
سبب تضخم ما زالت مرتفعتا
ويعتقد بعض الاقتصاديين ان رفع اسعار
الفائده لكبح جماحها قد تؤدي الى نتائج
غير محموده
العمل والسؤال كم من الوقت سيحتاجه
الاقتصاد من اجل التافه
في حين يرى اقتصاديون ان البنك الاحتياطيه
لا يملك بديلا عن رفع اسعار الفائده
للسيطره على خطر تضخم رغم كل هذه التحديات
تستقبل امريكا عامها الجديد بموسم
انتخابيا رئاسيه بدا مبكرا وهي منقسمه على
نفسها وفي ظل مؤسسات الدستوريه لا تقل
القساما محمد العلمي الجزيره
واشنطن